[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up youtube hey it's cameron with
motion science it's great to be here
today it's tuesday january 11th happy to
be here
uh from sunny sunny florida
uh how's everyone doing today let me
know uh who's here today
where you're uh watching from where
you're listening in from uh today we're
talking
about how i created the motion science
logo animation
i get asked a lot all the time through
emails through social media comments how
did i make this the motion science logo
animation
so i figured why not show you my project
files
break it down for you today and show you
how i did it
spoiler spoiler alert
it's pretty easy
but before i get into that i want to
hear from you i want to hear from you i
want to know who's here today and where
you're listening in from
uh so let me know
who's here today we've got uh let's see
we've got
um
all your crazy youtube names
he he60 all right got it al what's up al
good
good to see you here
uh paul paul rosenberg good afternoon
paul
uh we got amber here hi amber what's
going on
uh
paul's calling from new york
jacob from slovakia
amazing
amber's from wichita kansas amazing
shout out to kansas uh we've got jake
here from uh wichita as well amazing
uh let's see here
we've got
ganga diya
ganga diya
hopefully i'm pronouncing your name
correctly gangadiya
i'm so sorry if i'm pronouncing it wrong
uh you're from milan amazing
had a lot of italy
italian people here which is great
zack from
newfoundland canada what's up zack
paul is almost done with academy
volume what is it one
paul
remind
me uh she shavam
hi shavam
um
andrew andrew brightwell what's going on
andrew
from maryland
i think that's what md means right
uh sahej from india
uh
al's from bangladesh
uh
naoki from thailand
awesome and paul is in volume 1. amazing
amazing
great to have everyone here today
so if anybody is new here today
for those of you who don't know who i am
my name is cameron i've been a motion
designer for over 20 years working in
after effects in cinema 4d
i taught myself motion design and
animation started with animation then
moved into design
i built reels out of spec work that i
created for myself
these were personal pieces i wanted to
create to create a reel
that landed me my very first motion
design job
i was a remote remote freelancer for 13
years before
remote freelancing was even a thing
i've owned and operated two small
boutique post houses and i've had the
opportunity to build projects for
studios like
prolog films digital kitchen and
agencies like publicis and ogilvy and
mather and i've had clients
like 343 industries amazon american
express disney microsoft
mtv rca records sony
and so many more the list goes on and on
i've been very fortunate to have a very
lucrative and successful
motion design career
uh who else we've got
ricky here from brazil
amazing thank you ricky
appreciate that
uh and raghanath
hi raganov
uh one more thing before i show you guys
how i made the motion science logo
animation i want to let you know that i
have a free workshop
over at motion science
dot
tv
slash
workshop and let me actually get rid of
that
well i actually deleted that on accident
well you're not going to see it now
because i just screwed that up
it's motionscience.tv
workshop
where i show you seven secrets to
cinematic motion design
these are seven tips tricks and concepts
behind pro level motion design work plus
i give you access to a very special
offer
at the end that you're not going to find
anywhere else so please check it out if
you haven't already done so i can't
stress this enough i know i'm always
promoting this workshop
but it is awesome i know a lot of you
have taken the workshop
and have taken advantage of the offer at
the end
so i appreciate you
if you have not you are missing out
by not
checking out this workshop so plus you
get some emails with some um
other teaching content that i don't show
anywhere else
so
um hey lawrence goodtimes hd what's up
good to have you here laurent
all is good here
uh
lauren says the workshop's great can con
confirm amazing
so let me switch over here to my
screen
a couple windows here that
we don't want to
show
and move these out of the way
okay
so
we should be able to see my screen yep i
could see it there perfect um so the the
motion science logo is actually should
have had this kind of set up ahead of
time i'm going to turn off the audio
here
but this is a half resolution and it's
playing back here and this is at the end
of most of the videos i put out there
on social media channels if you take any
of the courses
you're going to see this at the end of
almost every video
uh there's a long version and a short
version
and this is it very basic
but a lot of people ask you know how did
i do this and i don't have i don't know
if i have the audio turned on here
let's actually
turn that on
yeah and unfortunately it's not going to
play through this you probably couldn't
hear that
but um
there's some some really simple audio
there with some piano hits that happened
and the piano hits as they happen is
that's when we see like the text
come up here and i probably should have
set this up ahead of time but these
piano hits hit and this text kind of
comes on
to those piano hits and they kind of
slow down and
that's how the words are revealed so let
me show you how i did this it's actually
pretty simple okay so we're gonna back
it up here and here's my audio layer go
ahead and lock that
so what i started off with here is i had
my audio layer here and i had just a
very simple
dark red solid background
and
a lot of times i will use a plain
just straight up black
solid um but sometimes when i actually
remember just to be honest like i don't
remember to do this so when i remember
to do this
i like to make my solids not 100 black
which is uh zero zero zero
on the uh the hex code down here
i like to give them a little bit of
color right just a little bit just a
little bit goes a long way so sometimes
i literally go up in this area here
which is just a little bit of gray a
little bit of brightness in there
sometimes i'll move it kind of over here
in the red area sometimes i like to kind
of play around the blues
um you know just like it's so so subtle
but it can go a long ways in design
right so
that's the first thing is i just have a
dark red solid here and actually all
this is just a background and this is
just
from
years and years of working in after
effects
i
tend to always just have a background
layer
sometimes if you don't have a background
layer it can screw up effects when
you're adding effects over the top of
things like adjustment layers
and it can just kind of change the look
of things so
a habit i'm in is i always add a
background layer so that's what that is
and then right below that like i said
it's audio and if i had ll on my
keyboard you're gonna see it shows me
the waveform and
in the waveform
every time we see a peak here like here
here here here there's one two three
four five six seven eight
nine
peaks and each time we see a peak
by listing the audio that's a piano here
a piano hit
and what i'm doing is i'm gonna actually
animate to that that sound and i'll show
you that here in a little bit
but that's all you're seeing here it's
just a it's a nice like string
uh quartet that kind of builds
you know just has a nice like if you
think of an orchestra it's just it's
building up and then there's a piano
head to bing bing bing bing bing okay so
that's what the audio waveform is so the
next thing we're going to do is we need
to bring in
the 3d shape and that's what i have all
the way up here at layer 6 is this 3d
shape we see
here and this is just from my logo
design this is actually how it ends when
i have just a still image of my logo
that's what we see is this mark here
and maybe i'll zoom in here a little bit
and
we'll try and go full res here
so that's what it looks like so all i
did to build this is this is a pre comp
okay and if you go into the pre comp
here
you're going to see
that if i turn on the alpha channel
which is by clicking this button here
this
is a simple box animation with an alpha
channel so we have
the layer at the bottom here if i solo
this and i turn off luma matte
you're gonna see that this is just the
render
and then i also rendered a alpha matte a
luma matte sorry which is this it's just
a white and black
render right so white
represents
transparency so anything that's white
is going to show through this and
anything that's black on this layer is
going to be invisible so by turning this
track matte
to luma matte that's what it does so the
white is what we're seeing through here
and we're seeing the actual render from
from cinema 4d
and the black is what's transparent okay
and i'll show you why i did this
why i chose this approach versus just a
render with an alpha channel here in a
minute
so how did i build this really simple
object i mean it's like i said it's very
simple so here in cinema 4d
it doesn't matter what version of
semi-40 you're in um
all i did was i took a tube
okay
and if i kind of go here if i i took a
tube object and i'm not going to jump
into too much about you know how to use
cinema 4d you should check out cinema 4d
quick start if you've
never used um cinema 4d but under create
primitive i have a what is this a tube
right here so i clicked on tube and if i
if you do this by default you're going
to see here that a tube is just
exactly what it sounds like it's just a
round tube but if i go down into the
parameters here i can actually change
the
rotation segments from 16 to four
and that creates basically the shape of
my
my my logo right it's like kind of the
mark um so that's all i did right made
it four sides which is what we see here
and then i also took down the um the
height to make it very thin
right so i think if
if i chain obviously the height is the
depth of it so that's
that
how did i do
oh the inner and outer radius so you can
make it thicker like this or make it
thinner
so i just made it very very thin
and i have very simple rotation
frames on this
so all this um
all this is doing is it's rotating
uh from 0
to 150
right here this is the value so if i go
back to the beginning we're at 90
degrees which is if you look here at the
camera
the camera is looking through
the shape here and actually let me
show you different perspective here
if i change this and i kind of move out
of the camera
you can see
that the camera is looking through it
right
just like this
and if i
what the actual
move is the camera moving back pulling
back from the shape and the shape is
just rotating so you can see the
camera's pulling back and the shape is
just rotating and coming into a resting
position that's all it's doing it's very
simple the camera pulls back
the shape rotates
and boom
there is our animation that when you
render it out
looks like this right this is what we're
looking through the camera
boom there is our very simple animation
so that's how we started it okay
uh the next thing we did
is i wanted to
create
the um like what we see inside of this
which is the i call it atmosphere and so
i'll solo that and that's these clouds
inside of here okay
now
the clouds are in there
and if we play it back i'll probably
have to go to half rest
to be able to play this back again
turn off the audio because i can hear
the audio but you can't
so we'll stop about there
and so you can see there's clouds in
there and then they're gone right so the
clouds are gone at this point you don't
see them inside there
so how did i do that well
back here in my 3d pre comp when i had
this top layer which is the white and
black values white is what we can see
black is what's transparent right now if
you don't understand luma
and alpha mattes
you can probably find some stuff on
youtube if you google it
i am also going to recommend after
effects academy um i think it's i can't
remember if it's volume 1 or volume 2.
someone asked me this the other day and
i forgot to look it up
i think it's volume 2 where we talk more
about this kind of stuff in detail
um but i have this this alpha render so
if i go back into my main render here i
have my atmosphere and i have it doing
the same thing it's doing a luma matte
of that that render above it
which you can see here here it is again
right so if i turn off
the
3d logo
oh and i should i just back up a second
here sorry getting ahead of myself
i also did a second pass okay where i
created another object buffer and that's
this this plane i have here if you if
you watch right here
i have a plane that's parented to my
tube so if i turn that plane on all it
is is a flat plane right there's no
depth to it just flat and it's sitting
inside of this
this mark so when the mark turns the
plane is turning as well
right and you can see it inside there
that is creating a second
luma mat which is what we see here just
this flat
plane like this
that's moving back in space right and
that's saying where it's white we're
going to see through it where it's black
we're not going to see through it
which is when i bring my atmosphere in
here and i don't have a luma mat there's
my atmosphere but when i turn on the
luma mat for this atmosphere
it's the same thing like it's kind of
like it's creating a a window for us to
see into right which is inside of this
3d
object here right now there's a little
bit of a movement here to the clouds the
other kind of pushing back as well so
the mark is pushing back and the clouds
are pushing back so how did i do that i
just i have a precomp here
super simple it's just a jpeg image that
i scaled down i started at 100 scale
and i went back to 75 scale here so if i
play it back this is all it is it's just
pulling back scaling back very simple
and where i ended this animation
was right here at frame 2 seconds and 18
frames okay so frame 68
if i go back to my main render
and i'm at 218
you can see here is where we no longer
right there that's where we no longer
see
the clouds again so that's why i ended
my animation right there because there's
no reason to animate beyond this point
because the clouds are gone at this
point
so
very simple and then on top of this
i did
a curves plug-in which i ended up not
using
i made it black and white so if i turn
that off you can see
you should be able to see there we go
that's back to like the blue clouds but
i want to make it black and white and at
the end i'll show you how i color graded
this
and i also used optics compensation
which all this does is if i back out a
little bit here optics compensation
if you use a um if you reverse it which
we see up here it defaults to a
non-reverse but you're going to see how
it kind of just
it just kind of creates this curve
and it's a real subtle effect and by
just applying just a little bit of a
curve towards the camera it just gives
it a little bit more visual interest
when we're looking at this
so it's not something you have to do
it's just something i chose to do
something i chose to add to it just to
give it a little bit of visual interest
there at the very beginning very very
subtle a little bit of optics
compensation
okay so we've got our atmosphere there
we've got which is basically our clouds
so if i i actually should probably call
this clouds to make a little bit more
easy to understand
and
object buffer's there
it's all good
so next what did i do so next i had
um these two illustrator layers here and
i left them in here to show you
but this is just motion science
when we created the motion someone
actually when i created the motion
science logo i made it in illustrator so
it's an illustrator file which we see
here
now what you can do is you can actually
take that illustrator file
and you can go to layer
create and you can create shapes from
vector layers which is what i did i did
this to the motion science layer and the
science layer and by doing that it turns
off these layers i'm going to lock them
again and it creates these new shape
layers which are one is motion and one
is science
okay so what did i do i applied um some
effects here that i end up not using
which are you can see here these are
sapphire effects that
i thought maybe i'd use them i end up
not so i turn them off and what i did
here is i'll bring up the timeline
is i used
transparency and masks to bring these on
so if i go back
and let's just solo
motion by itself okay and if i start my
preview right here
and i end my preview
here
so we're focused only on this area here
so i hit b and n to do that
what i've got is each of these letters
is just fading on
it's very very simple
i also have some mass here and i don't
remember actually why i used the masks
because i think these were all
they're all individual layers so you can
see when you create the shape layers
here m o t
i o
n each of these is its own shape layer
so i'd have to dive in and
look back of why
i created a mask because i honestly
don't know
why i needed a mask there
uh maybe
it has to do
um i don't know why it does if i deleted
these masks actually let me do that
yeah see that did throw it off
hmm
um what each of these masks is doing is
if you look here um each one of them is
on a letter
so again i'd have to dive back in i
can't remember i had to separate so i'm
separating each of the letters so they
you know come on i'm at random times
so that's what we see here and we also
see a little bit of flicker here okay if
you look really closely you're going to
see that there's just a little bit of
flicker in these letters this is
something i like to do a lot with my
animations it doesn't have to just be
type it can be anything
but what i did is i applied um so we've
got these transparency values right so
like the first letter that comes on here
is m
so there's just a very simple fade from
zero transparency
so it's over one two three four five six
seven seven over seven frames that m
is fading in like we see there after it
fades in though i've got a very simple
wiggle expression here
and if you follow any of my other
courses or other videos wiggle is my
most favorite expression it's the
expression i use for everything not
everything but a lot
and there's a lot you can do with it so
i use a very simple wiggle expression
and i said 30 times a second
i want you to
vary your opacity by a percentage of 20.
so if you think of opacity
opacity goes from zero to 100 zero you
can't see it 100 is completely you can
see everything right so i'm varying it
from because our opacity went up to 100
i'm saying that the opacity can drop all
the way down to 80
or back up to 100 a variable of 20. so
it could be 80 it could be 85 it could
be 86 it could be 92
whatever it's going to
change that number
30 times per second which creates this
really fast but very subtle flicker like
we see
in these letters here okay
so i did that with each of the letters
and then i also
timed each of these letters
so that
to these piano hits which i wish you
could hear
every time we would hear or i'm sorry
every time we would yeah we would hear a
piano hit like we see here's let me zoom
in just a little bit here
it's like we see one hit here here here
right if i go to motion and science
and i hit you
you're gonna see
that every time these um
moments happen
that's when like different um letters
are coming on so like one just popped on
here
um
[Music]
go to here one popped on right here so
these are hold keyframes so again
i can see here on on
up here these masks are dropping down to
reveal the letters i should have looked
into the mask more before i
did this but i timed out each of the
letters to the piano hits okay that's
the the ultimate idea here
so we've got that going on so that's
so let's turn on the layers that we're
using so if you talked about the
background the clouds
we've talked about the letters
the 3d
we've got all this happening now
next thing i wanted to do was i wanted
to
emphasize the letters even more right
um so what did i do i created a
actually we'll come back to this okay
we'll come back to this i'll explain
what this is do in just a second we'll
come back after we color grade this
uh what else we have so now we started
out adding effects to this okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add a glint
and let's see if we can see that glint
it's a little challenging to see
so we'll go ahead and leave that on uh
here's rays this is once easier to see
this is a very simple effect
uh for that comes with after effects
called cc light rays
and all this is doing
as you can see where it starts here
let's go back to half rows
see that light ray effect happening
there that's that's all it's doing
right so i've got it kind of i've got
the center point
here with a keyframe and i'm just kind
of manually tracking what's happening
with my mark here so i've got the center
point keyframed here which we see here
right there
and then it goes all the way to the end
here and it kind of just slides down
that mark so you can see it's just
starting up there and it's kind of
sliding down i've also got the intensity
keyframed here so it's zero here and it
bumps up all the way to what
98.6 but again i've got a wiggle
expression happening here
10 times a second the
amount of light rays is going to vary by
a value of 10.
okay so that's what's going on there
and
then the the intensity is is staying
about the same we're still at 97.5
and then we're going to drop that
intensity back down to a value of 21. so
the intensity it doesn't go away on the
light rays it kind of stays up there
sometimes we'll animate light rays in
and then out and it'll be gone but i
thought it was kind of interesting just
to keep this up
um the whole time it just kind of adds a
little bit of interest and you can see
that that wiggle happening right there
again there's like a flicker happening
with that light ray
um so i like that it's looking cool
like i said we also have a glint effect
happening uh this is a sapphire effect
that's very very subtle it's just adding
some extra light
to what we see here
next i added some noise okay and at half
res this noise looks way more intense
than it actually is this is one of those
effects that
you know ultimately when you're working
with effects and you're starting to kind
of polish your piece at the end
my belief is you want to go full res
whenever you can because
some effects will look different
at half res versus full res
so here's half res
and let's go up to full res
and you can see how much more subtle the
noise is now there is a lot of noise in
this i wanted to be a very noisy
piece um you know sometimes
15 noise is quite a bit um
a lot of times maybe i'll use five to
seven percent but for this one i wanted
to be very noisy uh so that's what we're
seeing here so
there's full res
and there's half red you can see the
difference there
next i've got
um
let's go ahead and actually flip this
well we'll keep it there
uh i added we'll skip this one we'll go
to looks right and this is kind of where
the color came in at
i went to my trusty plugin i love which
is magic bullet looks
this is a third party effect
you have to pay extra for through red
giant
but i pulled a preset i really liked
which i think is here under indy
is where i got it from um
i don't remember the actual one i used
that's one bad thing about looks
uh not that it's a bad player i love the
this this plug-in but it doesn't pull up
the name of what you started with
which is kind of annoying so it's hard
to go back and be like oh yeah i use
this to do it but you can see here
just by hovering over these different
looks you know how cool it can
basically look
there's all different types there's
grunge and
you know blockbuster and analog
this is just a plug-in that if i need
something quick
i will use this plug-in to kind of
get a quick look out of it um
again working with my own personal stuff
a lot of times i get lazy i just want to
knock it out as quick as possible
so that's why i went with this plugin
so we're gonna go ahead and cancel out
of this so i don't lose my look but
that's that's all it is it's just a look
applied over the top
and then we've got
a fade
which is right here
this fade
is just going to fade out the piece here
at the end
now what's different about this
is i'm not using
and sometimes what i'll do is i'll just
have a black layer and that's all this
is a black solid and i'll go from an
opacity of zero percent here so we don't
see it here and then by the end it's 100
opacity and it
basically is just a black layer over
everything and it just makes it look
like it's fading out well what i did
differently on this one
is i actually used a mask right so i
have a rectangular mask here and i
keyframed the mask so it starts here
and then what it does is the mask gets
smaller and smaller and it just makes
i should probably turn it on so you can
see it
it makes it look everything everything
is just kind of
fading out but there's also a nice
feather here a 300 pixel feather so very
feathered edge
and a keyframe that is easing in here so
it's not like it's going from
a really big square to like this
a large rectangle to a flat you know
rectangle it's it's starts fast and it
starts slowing down it's kind of more
cinematic to do that
um and if i show you the curve here it's
you know basic
ease in i think it's probably the
default ease in that's all we needed to
to create this so if i
preview this
from here and i'm probably gonna have to
go
let's want to wait here
wait it out i'm also gonna show you what
it looks like when you don't feather
this looks terrible if you don't feather
the feathering is key here
uh let's actually go half rose
hopefully you guys can't hear these guys
blowing the grass out here i know i say
this every couple weeks these guys are
here
super loud for me but hopefully you guys
can hear it
so
there we go and you can see it's just it
just creates this really just nice fade
out versus just putting black over the
top and and turning up the transparency
of the black solid layer now if i turn
off this feather so if i take it from
300 down to zero you're gonna see this
doesn't look good
and here we go
any day now see that looks terrible
right i mean now maybe for if you're
doing some type of sci-fi show and you
need it like these windows kind of close
in on it that might look okay
um but the key here is that
we're using
feather to do this and it's also helping
that i have an ease in keyframe it just
kind of slows everything down at the end
and just kind of makes it more cinematic
in that effect
okay
now these guys are right outside my
window
with a big blower
last layer i want to show you here is
this layer that we skipped earlier and
this is a medium gray scion solid so i'm
going to
solo this layer
so you can see this and what i did was i
took
the overall look that we applied to the
piece was a very you know green kind of
crunchy green color
so what i did was i kind of sampled
those colors and i just created a new
solid
if i go to layer solid settings
in this
range here right it's just a solid and
again i created a mask i just drew this
mask with my pen tool took my pen tool
and just started
you know drawing something like this but
what i was doing let me undo that
is i was looking at
the 3d shape
and the text right so i have my solid
and again
feathering is key here
okay so i just took my pen tool and just
drew around this in a very rough way
and then what i did was i turned up
my feathering which if we do this you
can start to see
kind of gives it like this glow
look but i wanted to be very very subtle
so i brought it all up to 267
and i took the transparency of it down
to 85 versus 100.
now when the layer starts which is right
here it's at zero percent because i
don't want you to see it yet
but as the type is coming on
that's when i want you to see it so here
it starts you can kind of see it here
let me go to full res again
and you can kind of see it coming i
don't know how much of this you can see
but it's here it's starting to come
through and it's coming through
and there it is it's sitting up there
it just kind of helps to separate
that text from the background so if i
turn off these soul layers
and bring it back up you can see with
that look applied
it just helps to kind of
bring a little bit more visual interest
to this so this is with the layer and
this is um whoops this is without
so look at that look how boring that is
right
when it resolves versus having this
layer in there
that's a solid layer it's all it is uh
and then glint again
i think you know
this piece could probably actually do
without the glint layer
i don't really see it happening much
or changing much in the overall look
maybe when we're
in this area here i think we're probably
seeing it
no we're still not so you know i could
turn that layer off
and call it a day
so
that my friends is um how
i built
uh this crazy very simple logo animation
that people really seem to like a lot
now you know with anything you could
always take it another luck to the next
level
maybe these edges
you know looking back at this these
edges could probably be softened up a
bit
um in here like when i look at this hard
edge here and here i probably should
have applied a little bit of
edge blur to this
which if i go in blur and sharpen
probably like a
i don't know fastbox
blur let me get rid of these effects i'm
not even using
um maybe something really subtle
yeah like see i don't know if you saw
that
but if you look at this edge here it's
actually too much maybe 1.5
so if you look at this
without
and width right it just blends it a
little bit more maybe it's just a one
i'm going to repeat edge pixels for the
edges over here
but really subtle
and that might still be too much maybe
it's a 0.7
uh that's just one of those those things
that as you become pro
you start focusing on those and like i
said i kind of rushed through this thing
when i built it
again look at this edge up in here so
that's width and that's without
and then i did something with the levels
here
which i'm not really seeing much of i
think it's actually just a oh i took the
grayscale values up just a hair so i
brightened it up
just a bit
so that's with levels
oh i darkened it just a bit
so with levels and without very subtle
effect again
just kind of
kind of fine-tuning things and getting
them closer to
what i think looks legit
and it's going to take forever to um
remember this but let me know guys do
you have any questions about this i mean
it should be pretty straightforward
sometimes i can
you know when i talked about the masking
of the letters i probably should have
had that shame on me
but um
the masking just like i said earlier has
to do with
showing
the letters
and
i don't remember why i did that
but uh yeah let me know if you have any
questions i'll be happy to answer them
about this logo animation and then we're
gonna wrap this one up
as soon as this finishes rendering
almost there i mean you guys saw this at
the beginning
just wish i could have got that audio
going
uh paul said working news the main use
for after effects would be motion
graphics would i love it to tour on how
to make documents look good flying in
and out highlighting phrases etc also
quotes and social media pull outs
yup that's cool
um
at some point in stylecraft i'm gonna
add some broadcast graphics to that
um it's gonna be included with that so
that's something to be aware of paul
you do learn a lot of things that would
relate to what you're asking for in
stylecraft
so i would invite you to check out
stylecraft i mean like that's where i
teach you more about the design side
and making things look really really
good
in after effects i'm teaching you how to
use after effects
as a tool and i do focus a little bit
you know on the design side in the
projects that we work on
stylecraft really goes into that stuff
so there you go
there is the logo animation without the
music
it looks pretty good you know i probably
spent
um
i don't remember now because i did this
a couple years ago 2019 actually
uh it's almost three years ago
but um
sochi i saw that you said uh where did
you get inspiration from i think it
would it was from lions gate from what i
remember
lionsgate has this kind of cloud
image we see it's very similar to the
beginning of this
and then they have these like 3d letters
that kind of fly out and i didn't want
to do that
i was like oh this would be kind of cool
i mean i literally made this logo
um
in a couple days just spent a few hours
on it i was like you know what because
this is the third logo for motion
science
and wasn't happy with the first two and
um wanted to change it up
so um
i made the logo in a couple days and
then made this in like a day or two
and i think it's because i saw that lion
skate
intro
it was inspired by that
but great question saatchi
uh zach
said in stylecraft
do you go in depth about aspects of
graphic design promotion i've been
freelancing for a while and feel like i
would like to design more rather than
work from clients supplied boards yeah i
mean that's what stylecraft is all about
it's all about
design
we do a little bit of animation but it's
like you know
i call it cinematic motion because it's
it's pretty
basic like push in push out side to side
um
i mean we do do some lessons on
animation i shouldn't say that we don't
because there are some that go kind of
deeper into it but the majority of
stylecraft
is about design how to create
beautiful compositions that then you
want to animate
so and we just changed some of the
wording on the website uh to kind of
focus more on that because i that's a
question i was getting quite a bit
so yeah
definitely design heavy
zach says another question and paul
that's awesome
get through after effects academy first
you're on the right you're on the right
path
uh from zach when you were creating spec
work for your unreal how did you
brainstorm ideas fill out placeholder
content thank you so much
uh great question zach
um
you know it's basically how i create any
kind of spec because i still create spec
work today i created a spec piece last
week
it's anything that i am
called to
that i want to design to get that
creative thing out
um so a lot of times i'll see pieces
right and be like that's really cool i
want to do my interpretation of what
that might be
and what happens is is like the piece i
did last week
i saw a piece on instagram
and i was like that's really cool
like i always say and um
i'm gonna i'm gonna so that was actually
two weeks ago that was like next week
which is last week i'm gonna build
something inspired by that and what i
find is i just i pulled it back up right
before i started designing the night
before i looked at it
okay put it away and then the next day i
go in and design and i create something
that has nothing and if you were to see
the two pieces you'd be like how was how
was this this
right but it's it's just being inspired
and wanting to create something that
inspires you
so when i was first starting out a lot
of logo animations uh were very
inspiring to me there wasn't all the web
content like we have today because this
is back in
you know
98.99 um so i'd see a lot of stuff on tv
and
be like that's you know that was pretty
cool like how it maybe like spun around
and moved and did this
so then i'd go and i'd find a logo for
some brand that didn't exist or was very
small or i'd just create
a very simple logo i'm talking simple
simple like type
and then i would animate it because for
me logo animation was something i saw
all the time i feel like it kind of
really exploded back then that was the
new thing like hey let's take our logo
and animate it
um so that's you know just for me it's
all about
just keeping all these different
inspiration references and then pulling
from those and i talk a lot about that
in a lot of my videos it's just having
mood boards to pull inspiration from and
you can pull inspiration from type from
texture from architecture from magazines
from other motion design pieces from
graphic design it doesn't matter
and it doesn't matter if you're pulling
all these different pieces of
inspiration from different
sources it's just all about
being inspired and wanting to create
work that you want more of right which
is something else i talk a lot about
there's a cycle that happens so
if you are
inspired by title design which is
something that was very inspirational to
me
um
i would create individual
title shots title scenes i wouldn't
create an entire sequence no because
that's too overwhelming right so i would
i would be inspired to design something
with a piece of type and some type of
background imagery and then animate it
in a very simple way because creating
that type of work putting that work on
my reel
and then putting that reel out to the
world
for a potential client to see and then
hire me to do that type of work it's a
cycle right so i create a spec piece of
a title design
a client hires me because they saw that
and they love it and they want to do
something themselves
uh they pay me to do that i create
another piece that then goes on my reel
again and it's just this endless cycle
so
yeah
all right my my peeps uh jake says very
cool
um
rachid
sorry from pronouncing your name wrong
thank you so much you're very welcome
um as i was always enjoyed being with
you guys here today
uh it's really fun to show you my logo
animation
hopefully you got some good tips and
tricks out of it there was some good pro
tips in there for you uh i'll be back i
plan to be back next week uh to talk
more about um
something else i don't know what it is i
know what i've got it written down
somewhere but i don't remember what it
is but it'll be fun and exciting and i
know you'll love it so
uh thanks for being here guys today and
uh i'll talk to you guys all very very
soon see ya